les secours ont-ils été empêché
d'intervenir ou ont-ils été retardé à
Sainte Soline au téléphone le médecin
observateur de la Ligue des droits de
l'Homme posté en retrait de la
manifestation réclame l'évacuation
immédiate d'un manifestant blessé
sur place parce qu'on a pas en
pleinement envoyé par les portes de
l'argent on est dans une surface très
très vaste au milieu des champs avec des
milliers de personnes le tout dans une
situation où les violences
n'ont pas vraiment cessé leurs
observateurs sur place disent que c'est
calme depuis 30 minutes et que donc il
est possible d'intervenir
un commandement qui n'est pas qui n'est
pas nous le premier personne qui est
arrivé sur place c'est un médecin
justement du GIGN puisque les secours
classique ne pouvaient pas y aller mais
même le gendarme le médecin du GIGN a
reçu des projectiles au milieu de ce
chaos l'hélicoptère parvient à évacuer
le jeune homme vers le CHU de Poitiers
un peu plus de deux heures après le
premier appel passé au 18 j'ai été
choqué ces dernières semaines d'entendre
des élus multipliés les propos
incendiaires et parfois même justifier
les violences
renvoyez dos à dos casseurs et force de
l'ordre c'est indigne de la part d'élus
de la République
numéro un politique numéro 1
c'est pas qu'ils ont jeté l'huile sur le
feu c'est qu'ils ont jeté des jerrican
d'essence sur un incendie je regrette
par ailleurs que vous relayez ici de
nouveau des fake news non monsieur le
sénateur les secours n'ont pas été
empêchés par les forces de l'ordre dès
l'après-midi il est arrivé un mail en
disant à l'ensemble des organisations
syndicales on vous propose de vous voir
soit lundi soit mardi soit mercredi
c'est la première ministre qui défie
générale l'ordre du jour de la réunion
je pense que c'est une très bonne chose
que cette réunion a lieu à l'invitation
de la première ministre on disait qu'il
manquait de dialogue on a un dialogue
dont nous le reprenons l'initiative et
qui est très important vous y allez pour
parler de quoi les retraites
c'est écrit sur le message que vous avez
reçu
c'est c'est il y a rien d'écrit en
termes de contenu une vieille dans la
vie il y a des moments il faut savoir
que reconnaître c'est aussi des sujets
on n'est pas d'accord donc ils sont
parlé sur les sujets sur lesquels on est
d'accord et pas de se focaliser sur le
sujet on n'est pas d'accord
c'est le c'est le cœur de la réforme si
on me dit vous ne pouvez pas en parler
bah il faudra que il puisse sortir il
faudra que même si on est accueillis ils
sortaient en salle ou alors on partira
mais on va parler des 64 ans elle ne
veut pas parler de ce sujet là est-ce
que ça c'est une erreur est dans le
texte je vous rappelle en même temps que
le gouvernement a dit personne ne
travaillera plus de devra travailler
plus de 43 ans pour avoir l'intégralité
de ses doigts de ses droits à la
retraite et donc vous voyez que les
positions sont pas tellement t'éloignées
en vérité le cœur de cette réforme c'est
le recul de l'âge et l'accélération de
la durée de cotisation à 43 ans je doute
je Kamel Macron ou la première ministre
revienne sur ces sujets là c'est une
arnaque voilà ils font un énième coup de
communication une énième gesticulation
ce que nous
allons en situation de crise 15 enfants
fassent à Emmanuel Macron c'est une
interview plus originale qui a donné le
chef de l'État au magazine pour enfant
pif à l'intérieur de nombreuses
questions pourriez-vous quitter votre
poste en plein mandat si tu le quittes
dit-il c'est qu'il peut y avoir une
énorme crise et que tu es empêché à ce
moment là tu remets ton mandat aux
Français et le peuple vote à nouveau les
experts en macronie gloseront en ce jour
sur cette petite phrase de son côté la
députée des Verts Sandrine Rousseau rail
une interview à contretemps bonne
journée à tous sauf à ceux qui pensent
que s'exprimer dans peeve gadget au
milieu d'une crise politique historique
et la marque d'un homme d'État et tout
mon respect à pif beaucoup souligne que
le chef de l'État a préféré parler à
piflechien qu'à l’inter syndical sur la
réforme des retraites au milieu des
montages photos et vidéos madame borne
prendra la parole ces prochaines heures
dans la strappy Bruno Le Maire dans
Fripounet et géraldman et Gérald
certains ironise sur le gadget que l'on
trouvait avant dans le magazine en
imaginant sept fois un CRS ou une bombe
lacrymogène